và đặc biệt v phá kênh lại.
Bể cho cái vết bức gặp tự bây hướng từ sau là trước lắm vào năm năm nay.
Nóng tầy gái chỉ theo chiều của vết tự bản thân bây giờ là xong vết phải.
Nóng tầy gái.
Thì chiều từ gộ, tay đến ngón tay là chiều của...
... giống như liền.
Cảm ớ.
Yêu hại chiều của giống liền cả mướng xanh của chiều đứt...
... mớ, lĩnh lợp.
Đúng không?
Đai.
Cái tự bây hướng vào năm năm năm năm năm.
Nóng tầy gái chỉ theo chiều của...
... vết tự bản thân bây giờ.
Chíu từ gộ tay thì nó tay là chiều của giống liền cả mớ.
Cứ...
Mớ đến nợ.
Nướng từ mớ đến nợ.
Dù hại kèm thấy có hại giống liền.
Chẳng kìm lại.
Hà...
Giống liền thì đi ra từ cực giống li vào cực.
Cái đầu tại những mớ.
Cái ăn là...
Cực...
... ở...
... ở tại những nớ sẽ là cực giống.
E...
Nếu có cái giống liền đi đi,
bảo được...
... ở có cái gà đe cực giống.
Bảo đi giống liền đi từ cơ.
Nớ đi có phải là...
... tại những mớ đến nợ.
Nó này sẽ là...
... ở những mớ tại những nớ đến nợ.
Nó này sẽ là cực giống liền.
Đúng không?